I am a large filling that fell out of my wisdom tooth and it's been like that for over a year now.
The back edge of the tooth is gone. I finally found a new dentist after insurance changed.
Is it better to pull the tooth or get a crowd as far as health goes? I worry about
cavitations with pulling the tooth and bacteria getting the tooth sealed in with a crowd.
I know you're a dentist but I'm wondering if you have any insight. Well, it really depends on how
much damage is to the tooth. It's salvageable. Yes, if you do get the tooth, if you just get it filled
and they can build up the tooth with the filling, sometimes that's the best. Can you seal in bacteria
by crowding it? It is possible. The worst is getting a root canal done because then the whole tooth
is a hotel for bacteria. But usually if you have a crowd and it's a tight fitting crowd where there's
no gap in the crowd, it's sealed with a sealant so there's no air in there. Then the chance of bacteria
in there is much less. So again, I'd refer to your dentist in this. I don't have a dentist but
is there a chance if you pull the tooth that you can end up with cavitations? Yes, if they do an x-ray,
they're going to see how deep the roots are and that can be an issue. So yeah, just you're
going to weigh all those things out. I think if the roots are strong enough and healthy enough
and the tooth is still healthy other than that damaged part, get it filled and put a crown on so
that you still have use of the tooth might be the best way to go.